well last week
we opened one of our shows
with me reading
extensively in fact we followed up we
opened part of a program with it and
then we followed up the next day on it a
new york times story talking about an
increasing
pattern
a new trend
in education particularly public
education government education in this
country
which is
more school closures for reasons
either tangentially related or just
unrelated to covet
that we had schools closed in far too
many places
massively detrimental to kids to their
mental health to their development
you look at learning loss you look at
all kinds of
emotional and physical problems
social problems
i mean that list is now long the data
the clarity that we have on the
enormous
profoundly harmful disservice that was
done to millions of kids around the
country based on
anti-scientific decisions to close and
then keep closed
schools even when
we were looking at real-time data
real-time outcomes
in europe
in the uk
in private schools around the country in
states that were open like florida
there were still a lot of places and
generally the more democratic and the
bluer you get the more likely kids were
locked out of classrooms
for longer
because of this unholy alliance on this
issue between the democratic party
and the government public teachers
unions
and i think that we are going to be
grappling with
the ramifications and the consequences
of that
for a long time i think we have barely
scratched the surface of the harm
inflicted on kids
and yet
now that schools have reopened
almost everywhere at this point
belatedly disgracefully belatedly in a
lot of places you now have teachers and
teachers unions saying oh gosh this is
so overwhelming we're beleaguered we're
tired we're burnt out and so schools and
we read extensively from that the new
york times story
which interviewed parents to shocked and
angry parents in places ranging from
michigan
to nevada and all over the country
when school districts just at the drop
of a hat say we're actually going to
close schools now
for two or three days at a time or
every friday for the rest of the month
or
the next
entire week with two days notice
as if there hasn't been enough learning
loss as if the kids aren't already
trying to catch up
locking them again out of classrooms
for new reasons
is
absolutely
outrageous and shocking and yet it's
happening
and the explanation is that these
teachers it's just really hard on them i
have no doubt
that there is some burnout and fatigue
and frustration and that there are
challenges some of the challenges by the
way caused by or certainly exacerbated
by school districts and states decisions
to keep kids out of school for a year
right there are
there are outcomes and there are
consequences for policy decisions
and when you create some of those
challenges yourself
or make them worse than they need to be
then running away from the challenges i
think is not acceptable
and i feel like i always have to say i
have people in my family close friends
who are public school teachers i'm a
product of public schools
i got a great education
i'm not anti-teacher i'm not anti-public
school
i am
pretty anti-public school
union
what these union bosses have done what
they have wrought
and what they continue
to wreak
because
it is just to me unfathomable that you
have
this situation cropping up the way that
it is oh the teachers need mental health
days everyone needs mental health days
it's been the pandemic has been hard on
everyone
a lot of people are burnt out how do you
think
the guy who
drives the 18-wheeler who never had a
day off probably worked even more just
to keep the country running in the
middle of covid when there was no
vaccine how do you think he feels think
he's a little burnt out what about the
doctors and nurses working around the
clock with people dying around them
every day for months on end are they
burnt out
what are the people stocking the shelves
at grocery stores who couldn't take a
day off because we all have to eat you
think they're burnt out what about when
their kids can't go to school and they
have to figure out how to deal with
child care or how to pay for child care
could that perhaps lead to some burnout
and financial hardship yes of course it
could
and i think to pretend that it is
uniquely hard on teachers who get a lot
of time off as it is
many of whom did not
show up or darken the door of a
classroom for more than a year i think
that is extremely tough to swallow that
story
including for many parents
which brings us to
the latest story about this phenomenon
from the washington post this is not
just a minor thing happening one or two
places and i'm latching on to it and
blowing it up because it makes for good
you know conservative talk radio where
we just want to demonize teachers that's
not what this is about it's about
defending and protecting kids
where adults have betrayed them over and
over again throughout this pandemic and
continue to do so
and it is much more widespread and
growing than people want to imagine
which is why it's shown up not just in
the new york times but also the wall
street journal we've quoted local news
stories and then this from the
washington post headline
schools add half days
to beat teacher
fatigue in a school year widely
described as the most grueling of the
pandemic
schools have come up with at least one
fix for teacher burnout
more half days
and they cite examples this is a local
story in the post in virginia and
maryland
where they are converting full days into
half days
they're quoting officials saying this is
due to quote stress and anxiety
caused by the wearing down of staff like
none of us have ever seen before
one official says we want our teachers
to be fresh to be energized to be in a
better spot so they're just giving them
more time off on top of the
time off that they already get which is
more than most people in the workforce i
think we'd all like to be fresh and
energized and in a better spot
here's part of the game that they're
playing here
a baltimore county parent who's
testified against these decisions
publicly is telling state officials that
the trend in maryland is at odds with
the state's decision to require school
systems to provide 180 days of in-person
learning this year because half days
don't affect
that count
right so half days
would
my understanding is quote unquote count
as a day of in-person instruction even
though it's half a day
and let's be honest let's be perfectly
frank here for a moment think about when
you were in school
back when you were a kid
how did your brain compute half days i
remember maybe i'm just speaking for
myself but i suspect many of you are
going to nod along with this
when you had a half day of school it was
kind of like
a fake day
like yeah you had to show up you did
some stuff but your mind was already on
where were you going to go for lunch
when school let out because it was a
different sort of day
it was not a real full day in your mind
because it was a half day you were not
in the headspace of normal learning
then of course you've got parents
working parents
half days are a huge pain in the rear
end for them because it throws off the
whole schedule and the needs for child
care and the whole plan
what we need as a society kids parents
everyone what we need more than ever is
normalcy predictability
after so many disruptions and what we
have now
is a trend away from that
and it's no longer
the virus it's no longer covered it's no
longer outbreaks it's no longer
phony excuses like oh we need to
sanitize the ceiling or whatever in
these schools it's oh the teachers are
burning out and so they need more time
off and so sorry kids you're gonna have
more half days which we all know how
kids react to half days i remember
and sorry parents figure it out
it's a half day
you've got a full day at work but tough
luck
it's like the hits just keep on coming
and so they quote teachers unions bosses
that are in this story of course they're
all in favor of this
desperately needed an important step one
of them said right not even the end game
here
from this teacher's boss this union boss
perspective
it's an important step toward what they
need
god knows what they have planned and i
guarantee you some of them will try to
get away with whatever they think they
can
they've had this experiment for the last
year and a half in
basically throwing up two middle fingers
over and over again to parents and to
kids
and it seems like the lesson so far has
been let's push more
so on top of the
days off
and the random school closures
now you've got this other
addition to the repertoire
half days
to replace full days
and that's not all
when we come back i want to tell you
about other things happening in public
schools
out in california which is like the
birthplace of most of our madness in
this country
they want to push equity
and so wait till you hear what they're
going to get rid of in some of these
school systems just abolishing something
we'll tell you about that
plus oregon also out there on the
left coast
what their equity pursuit
has brought about we will bring you
those stories as soon as we come back as
we just get rolling here tuesday edition
of the guy benson show stay tuned
you